unfortunately
yes she she went there
cement's mom threatened to take her own
life if he marries jenny and this
tactic of hers it actually worked
in this cookie should i give it
did you see the smirk did you see it
she tried to hold it back but it just
seeped through
we also have to talk about benyam
popping the question
to ariella even after she was annoying
him
all day at his favorite holiday festival
it was cute
hey 90 day fans fam it's malicia
we finally made it to the other way
season two
finale and the couples they have been
on a journey i thought i was an
adventurous person
but please they've made me think again
as usual with the season finales we're
gonna cover
where every couple's love story stands
and after that one of the season's most
talks about
cast members ariella will reveal
the biggest lesson she's learned from
her first
90 day run all right let's take a look
at the moments
that led up to submit's mom's threat
we love each other age doesn't matter we
love each other
i have daughters i am a mother my
daughter married somebody that i didn't
want her to marry
but i accepted it you know why because i
saw my daughter
happy you're taking the revenge of your
daughter from my son
what no then what
cement needed to hop in and clear that
one up
but he was too busy off in his head
it took jenny raising her voice a little
too loud at his parents to
snap him out of it there's no talking to
these people
no talking there's no talking
submit said whoa wait a minute now you
you can't do that he probably was
thinking i know my parents are out of
line
but only i can react that way you jenny
you're making it worse after she calmed
down
cement went ahead and told his mom and
dad that there
is nothing they can do to stop him
from marrying her and that's when his
mom responded with
this
jenny is like okay then his dad
came in and co-signed the threat
but he made sure to exclude himself
she will commit suicide
this is what submit calls emotional
blackmail
apparently he's used to this from his
parents
but he doesn't want to take any chances
and
gamble with his mom's life so he told
them that he won't
marry jenny which i get i'm sure he's at
a point where
he doesn't know what his mom would do
for now
cement plans to find another way to get
jenny citizenship
i'll find out a way to keep you here
[Music]
or else i'm just gonna go back to
america that's gonna be it we're gonna
either continue with a long-distance
relationship or it's just gonna be done
i'm not gonna give up on you until you
do
that's sweet and all but seriously when
do you get to a point where you throw
your hands up and say hey
maybe we're forcing this thing the
timing
the circumstances maybe it's just not
meant to be well according to jenny
this is submit's last chance or she's
done
the episode ended with submit gifting
her something she's always
wanted which i guess kept hope alive for
this relationship
this is like a promised ring
don't embarrass me
wow finally
finally i finally got my ring
yay the ring which i'm giving jenny
it's something about commitment it's
something about promise
it's something about expressing our love
towards each other
cement loves him some ginny
he really does it's sweet all right well
it's ariella
and binium time these two along with
baby avi went to a celebration for
timcot
which is an orthodox holiday where
people celebrate the baptism
of jesus christ on the way there
binyam revealed that he wanted to
propose to ariella
at some point during the day so
as a viewer i'm excited i'm ready to see
how he's going to
top the question but then these moments
begin to happen where you could clearly
see ariella was irritating binyum
so bad and i just started to think
okay we're not going to get a proposal
as a matter of fact we may not need one
there's a lot of people here and there's
like open
sun and the speakers are really loud
the baby is only one month old
if a lot of water gets done i'll be
really upset there's hundreds and
hundreds of people
all jumbled together in front of these
priests that are like hosing people down
with holy water out of a garden hoses
she's afraid that her baby is gonna get
knocked upside the head her concerns are
valid
i would be doing the same thing i don't
care if you call me paranoid anxious or
whatever
that baby is fresh right now i'm some
ads
are she's knowing person
ariela came to the realization that
although she had the right to be worried
she could have expressed herself in a
better way so
she gave avi to binium's sister and went
to go find her man
when she found him he quickly got over
their fight
and popped the question
oh my god
you were supposed to do that research
beforehand
but besides that i love how he
incorporated the lemon
which he says is a cultural tradition if
you like a girl
you throw a lemon at her he even had a
flag made
for his now fiance so binyam
actually put some thought into this i
see now why it wasn't so easy for him to
just
call it off they still have a lot to
work through
but i believe in this couple mainly
because ariella she's a ride or die
up next yazan and brittany when it comes
to yazan
who literally risked his life for love
britney
tried to talk him into moving to the
united states
after learning about how much danger
they are in
by staying in jordan but after talking
to his brother
he realized that that's not the best
idea for him
the plan now is for his brother to talk
to their parents
so yazan can move back home in brittany
well she booked a flight back to the u.s
before the coronavirus
shut down the jordanian borders
yes on really does stand to lose a lot
by marrying me
so there's just a lot that we both have
to think about
[Music]
another
you tried all right well speaking of
flights back to the u.s
just three months after her big wedding
ceremony
to jihoon devin revealed that quarantine
took a major toll on their relationship
so she's returning to america for one
month
so they can have some space which really
sounds like
she's not going back to korea
well tim and me lisa also had a very
hard goodbye
we're used to seeing tim cry but it's
not often
we see melisa show emotion tim headed
back to the states to get his money
right
with plans to return to colombia hold on
we are going to round things out with
some great
news kenneth and armando found out that
they can get married now
and armando's daughter hannah
her reaction was priceless
happy exactly
[Music]
was familiar for the same thing
she's so cute all right before we wrap
things up
as i promised let's take a look at what
ariella says
is the biggest lesson she's learned from
her first
90 day run we mainly decided to do it
because
you know binyam is a dancer he's you
know he has all these talents and we
thought it would be
well i thought it would be really good
for him and i was encouraging him to do
it and for some reason i got it in my
mind that like oh well people will just
focus on him
and that will be you know that will kind
of take the heat off of me but as the
you know as time goes on i realize oh
like wow that's not true at all you know
especially
i had the baby and this you know we he's
half the story i'm half the story or
you know so um it's kind of in a way
it's given me
a little bit more confidence because i
was afraid how i would feel like when i
got negative comments
online and any negativity i was afraid
also that i get so many positive
comments too that i might become full of
myself
yeah but i i realize that you know i
have kind of an
even killed personality where i'm not
really terribly affected by the
positive comments and i'm not terribly
affected by the negative comments so
it's taught me something about myself
that's a pretty good lesson
now the big question is will her first
run
be her last well we just have to wait
and see
all right 90 day fans fam to stay
updated
on all the latest news coming out of the
90 day universe
make sure you stick with e.t because we
are covering it all
i'll see you next time
you